[Applause]  the North Koreans came pouring over the  38th parallel This Is War and we're up  we knew this day might come it doesn't  make it any easier  [Music]  commanding officer called you one of the  best  it must be hard being the Naval aviator  it's the toughest job there is but you  don't think that you'd be in a squadron  with a colored Aviator  can't take it how many times people have  told me to give up quit  not even  that's why you can't always do what  you're told what do you want me to do  just be balling man leave alone in this  guy Jesse  remember you belong down here with us  too okay  I need everyone sharp and ready those  boys are Holding On by their fingernails  we bring everyone home  and then what you're fighting for  [Applause]  show off that was pretty good it's good